[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants alors vous vous êtes
vite endormi héros soir oui c'est très
bien aujourd'hui nounours a préparé un
beau jeu pour nicolas et pimprenelle et
pour vous aussi je peux y avait pas trop
j'ai hâte de voir mes petits amis et de
jouer avec nous mais oui mon gros
nounours mais ne traîne pas
cinq minutes c'est juré patron propos
qui croient qu'il aimerait jouer à noyal
agneau au nom sur mon bonjour les
enfants
je n'aime pas les loups ils sont
méchants mais je vais vous montrer un
jeu fluide à cette très facile la voilà
au sol ou une écharpe sur les bleus vit
donc on ne voit rien tout vent comme une
toupie
donc on ne sait plus où l'on est on
attrape quelqu'un voilà c'est pas
preneur c'est simple j'ai on voit tout à
travers ton et chat tu as triché nos
bonnes ici on va te mettre une écharpe
comme ça oui
[Musique]
le typhon je tousse c'est toute chose en
mai matin comme on dit
et bélie nemours essaie de nous attraper
maintenant oui oui ce que je suis
bonjour bonjour boum c'est toute chose
sinon j'allais on n'est pas là oui je
tombe on n'est pas le sétois front chaud
c'est nicolas about a perdu cette fois
non c'est pas un problème
regarde où elle se produisait je ne
pouvais plus respirer les vaches pas tu
tombes mignon écoute pour te faire
plaisir on va te chanter notre chanson
et on va tout de suite au dodo bon je
vous écoute d'accord moi c'est la fin de
la journée c'est le moment de jeu go
j'ai noté son corps
nos amis ils s'en vont tous au lit non
c'est long aussi sur son nuage
certaines mamans le manche ressemble à
tant il nous dira fermez vos yeux et
d'eau mais tous les deux non ça m'a bien
dans notre lit nos songes well aubenas
nuit sa grosse voix me faisait plaisir à
mme raja vais m'endormir
quand je vais m'endormir
safra nous fait plaisir
[Musique]
bonne nuit
bonne nuit de noce venu nicolas
on y apprenait
[Musique]
bonne nuit mes chers petits enfants
allons en route nounours on roule pas
trop fait de beaux rêves
à demain
[Musique]
on
oh
[Musique]